[Music]
three
two one action hey guys welcome back to
off the record where we talk about
what
this whole is about to put his rolex in
his mouth
[Music]
dude look at this i'm this close to buy
another one
no to selling oh [ __ ] thing why
you're gonna salvage everything how much
yourself do it sell for
except for my mountain bike
and my surfboard maybe a mountain bike
and a surfboard it's on the wrong hand
my friend i know i didn't fit
let me know but why do you want to sell
your rolex for i don't know i'm thinking
about
that one has that that one has very good
sentimental
values but the other one you have two
yeah i could sell that one but the other
one that dropped in price so it's kind
of like [ __ ] dude
oh you might buy the other one i think
he's looking at ones that are similar to
other ones oh is it master two
how much is that the one you have i
don't know whatever the market value is
well i'm just thinking about it hold on
guys i'm not ready to sail you know
i know there's so many people out there
they're ready to buy hey
i got a bunch of weapons how small is
your wrist oh wait
there's i got connectors for you it
could it could it could you could resize
it what
can i can i buy one of your non-gun
weapons
sure what like what like is nordic
yeah like samurai sword you don't have
to i have an axe you can have right here
we we don't have any sort of weapons
other than that oh don't say that this
will say
i have an act cause i can't be like yeah
welcome to our
but we do have a security system by the
end of this video today i'm gonna
they're gonna go home with a weapon so
don't yay we finally get away um
no well one thing is
[Music]
the idea of minimalism like i got a lot
of [ __ ] right and i can always buy more
[ __ ] it's
the thing is like what really makes me
happy
is one playing outside in nature yeah
and two investing
that those two things ex excite the [ __ ]
out of me the rush dude just get
five white shirts five black shirts have
you like nice stuff if you ever need it
like
tucked away just like a few of them
right same shorts same pants
like two pairs of pants five pairs of
shorts or like two pairs of shirts yeah
you could just give all your sentimental
value things like your childhood stuff
to your mom she holds it for you and
then you have
or just invest everything into nature
like throw your money into the wild
casey's like ooh got a new one that's
already on it
yeah i don't know so all this other
stuff right i feel like
okay the more [ __ ] you got the more
things you have to clean
the more things you got to stow away i
just started thinking about this stuff
right because i got a big
place for by myself and i'm like
when you have a big space it's easy to
fill it
you don't want roommates i don't want
roommates i want to i want to get away
from this
because i was like what makes me happy
is not the space
what makes me happy is when i'm out with
my friends i just use this space to cook
and sleep
so i don't do much for you no like it
maybe it will change if i have a family
and
you have a living room so you have to
buy a tv you got to buy a couch
you don't sit on it and watch tv no i
never watch tv that's why it's like this
is not according to my lifestyle
so it's wasteful yeah so i'm like uh
what can i be doing like for example
with my rent or right whatever right
that's
four g's a month am i happier
using that 4gs on just buying crypto
or freaking even gambling that money
yeah that [ __ ] makes me way [ __ ]
happier right
yeah or like if i saved it up for a
couple of months
and let's say my friend knocks on my
door goes hey man i got this wild ass id
you won't have a door though if you
saved it up that knocks
on my van door zipper yeah he just
scratches it like that
okay they scratches the yeah he goes hey
i got this badass idea i hear them
walking towards you
yeah you don't even need to scratch all
i need i just need like
20 g's wait really quick isn't that
really funny how when you're camping and
you're inside of a t or am i the only
one
that when you're camping you're inside
of a tent and i close the door for some
reason
i feel like i it's like soundproof
almost but then when i hear you guys
outside
and like making like you know walking
and stuff i'm like oh [ __ ]
this really does not provide any sort of
like muffling yeah i'm in the tent and i
can hear people snoring
yeah what do you think they're doing i
think they're sleeping yep yeah you can
hear every single russell
it's because it's not sound proof when
you close i know that
but because it's enclosed i just do you
think it is yeah yeah i feel like
psychological well you know when you're
in a room and you have like the the tv
on and the
the fans blasting in your ear but like
it's white noise it's white noise it's
like you forget about it yeah like
equalizes
true that's how i feel like camping is
so imagine if i'm camping right
and then nadim comes over he scratches
the tent and i open it
what's up and he's like yo i got this
best idea i'm gonna make the best kebabs
i just need 20 grand for the kebab truck
let's [ __ ] roll buddy bam let's do it
right and then like we just go and and
tour california with nadeem's kebab
truck or wonder if i was like yo like i
got this crazy idea like we should move
into
a house now we have the money to pay for
it we could sleep we're not showered
properly
and not sleep on the floor and then he's
like down and he takes his tent and he
puts it in a room
in your house because i got this tent i
don't need a tv
yeah you live in your backyard yo
there's a technology
wait as an investor you don't need to
live together you just buy you a house
but i'm like okay dude like you love
nature i got this crazy technology that
you can just stare into this uh
little screen that can transport you
anywhere and you save the money that
you'd be on
i'm sitting on his couch like watching
the screensaver of the tv of nature and
i'm like this is [ __ ] dope you're
just watching the grand canyon portal
dude
they should [ __ ] invest in this [ __ ]
this is tent it's like right to the
bathroom
[Laughter]
yo i got you this this dope it's like a
room inside of a room it's called the
closet
you just sleep in there oh next level
it's a room in a room yeah i think those
things
excite me right and then if i if i
can do that every other month or
whatever and i just it some of them will
win some of them
will fail maybe most of them will it
doesn't [ __ ] matter because that kind
of stuff uh
i don't know it's it's fun to me you
know that i like those kind of
experiences
and then that's building right even like
simple things of like minimizing how
much you're spending on like food or
netflix if you're not watching it
all these other subscriptions in there
you're like oh like a pornhub like you
know that's
adds up you know yep you have a pornhub
subscription what do you feel like do
you feel like let's say uh you commit
you're not camping you're not visiting
nature
you're like you live there now right so
i feel like knowing my personality i
might go minimalism because it's like
cool
right and i like delete everything and i
just take my tent very very chill
but then if i stay out there for years
i'm gonna eventually get a bunch of [ __ ]
for like outdoors i'm gonna have the
sickest bike the sickest rope
illest knife nicest compass greatest
magnifying glass to start fires
awesome pots you know what i mean it's
going to turn like this
yeah i'm like that's a big ass
magnifying glass wait where do you store
that that's not minimalism he's going to
[ __ ] torch a whole tree
where would you want to live like
actually in nature or he's like l.a
river smaller house
oh yeah i could i could stay in family
cars
i could do van life i mean i haven't
really get an rv but i just feel like
me using that big space is kind of
wasteful
because i'm not using it like to the
full
of it right so maybe a family would
appreciate it more
so for me i'm like what do i really need
and then i was exploring the whole
couple of weeks and i'm like okay my
bedroom
a bathroom my kitchen and my garage
those are the only items that i really
use so that's like a
500 square foot spot yeah pretty much
but i actually use my garage for a lot
of other things than just
like i don't even park my car there
that's my gym that's you know so
yeah and so you could almost get away
with just like a public storage unit
and like a bush i can or get a house
where the garage is bigger than the
house
i can do that too it's like six car
garage and the house is like this yeah
that's our house like the downstairs i
feel like our garage is like just the
same as like the
kitchen and living room and all that
pretty much yeah how many car garage do
you have
two oh that's big yeah damn
but now we added more living space in
our downstairs now that we're doing our
backyard it really feels like an
extension of the downstairs living
spaces
yeah i think i think it's different like
like you know how like when you live
um at your first house right and it was
perfect for like
two people yeah but then when you add a
baby and then
uh jio's mom and then all the dogs and
all that then it feels small
and it feels like oh you need space
where i feel like
me alone it's just too much space even
though the space is small
let's get a boyfriend
[Laughter]
that is that is a way if you don't have
a boyfriend
sponsored by adam and eve you get some
plastic [ __ ] you get a plastic [ __ ]
dildo silicone dildo all kinds of
different sex
toys to spice up your sex life even if
it's by
yourself because adam and eve says the
best part of staying home
is playing at home yep that's safe sex
take advantage of the down time
and choose almost any one item at 50
off baby when you do you also get 10
free
boredom busting gifts including six
spicy movies
a three-piece bonus kit best of all
free shipping delivered discreetly
right to your door so go ahead and make
all those nasty choices because your
neighbors aren't gonna be able to see
yup just remember to use the offer code
otr
that's otr at checkout adam and eve has
thousands of products to make you glad
that you are staying
at home sex toys make being at home
so enjoyable hell even shopping from
home is more enjoyable when you are
shopping
sex toys yeah cause there's no one that
can shame your ass that's true
adamadive.com and use offer code
o t r and get one item at
50 percent off wow you know
i imagined like the discreet packaging
of like a giant dildo
right but it's just like perfectly
shaped as the dildo
but it's just the screen on it man
that wouldn't be very discreet they
wouldn't do that it's been a while since
i [ __ ] the fake [ __ ]
it was a a meme well they got the
packaging supposed to be the screen it
was like
just two balls
wait what was it though it was something
innocent was it ping pong paddle and two
balls
all right oh yeah something funny no i
think that was a sketch we're supposed
to do
but then when you actually open up it
was like a rose and like something nice
no i remember seeing that it was like
some innocent toys but it looked like
it looked phallic i don't remember but
anyway
so you want to live in oh yeah um man
i'm just considering a lot of things i
think
it never really occurred to me i got so
comfortable you know when you get
comfortable
you kind of get used to something
because i love my place i love the
neighborhood everything's pretty good
but then i i i think i'm thinking more
along the lines of like
how can i enhance the quality of my life
you need a van life girlfriend
maybe maybe that i mean i don't i'm just
considering everything like sail
sailboat living in a boat like there's
this dude right he parks a boat
and it's like a [ __ ] yacht it looks
sick as hell him and his brother live in
it
and he's paying like just a couple
hundred bucks a month
and this sick ass boat and then all of
these apartments around them are like
five thousand dollars a month and he's
sitting there and he's like
on the water on the wall the boat like a
quarter million dollars oh true
uh the boat looked pretty sick like it's
like it looks like hundreds of thousands
of dollars
but he's only paying a couple hundred
bucks a month really i thought that
start me off with a couple hundred
thousand i'll see what i can do
wait i thought parking your boat just
like parking an rv or any of that
that's probably why he's paying the
couple hundred and you know yeah so if
you add everything together it's only a
couple hundred bucks a month
uh individually so maybe like it's like
a thousand or whatever if you add it all
up but just between him and his brother
yeah it was just it was just really good
and i was just like what the [ __ ] so
i think there's this whole movement too
going on with uh millennials and gen z
and we realize that we don't have to be
as wasteful as our parents generation
and like
for me aren't we more wasteful i am i
think
or more wasteful because i actually want
a ranch i want like a
40 acre place that i could go like
off-roading and camping and doing
stuff on that i know no one else is
going to be there but me and my friends
yeah that's what my cousin's trying to
do in orlando
so that's why they were looking into
that property remember i mentioned oh
yeah yeah
had like an airplane hangar right yeah
i'm like what in orlando like that's
freaking crazy but our parents
generation and like even
in between us like the boomers right you
were stigmatized
if you didn't move out and buy a house
and do all the cookie cutter [ __ ]
whereas our generation is questioning
that [ __ ] and we're like
why do we have to have a mortgage why do
we have to do that yeah
because i'm like now that there's so
much info on being financially
um like intelligent and being an
investor and all that we didn't have
access to this info
when we were younger right yeah so like
now that everyone does they're like
oh man i'd rather be like elon and just
[ __ ] go a thousand percent on what i
believe in and just live in an apartment
and then like thousand times
whatever you know like i don't know and
then though that's being accepted now
and also like in
you know having roommates in your late
20s wasn't an accepted thing it was kind
of
ins and still in some places it's still
not accepted but in l.a
how the [ __ ] are you going to survive
yeah that's true that's true
do you remember the beginning of that
one sublime song like
he was living in an apartment with two
with a few and then
do you remember that smoked two joints
in a morning yes and they were smoking
marijuana cigarettes
marijuana yeah exactly so even in that
little like bit
like the audio clip it just highlights
how having roommates were just so
frowned upon even like
yeah it was weird right so i think
even that concept people were pressured
to spend
money they were pressured to have like
that life
and i think that a lot of our parents
generation went into debt
um because of the stigma that they
didn't want to have
uh they'd rather be in debt and buy the
house and keep up with the joneses and
just have the cars and all that
then uh to live with the shame of like
doing things they want maybe you know
the alternative way or whatever
yeah because even back then too like
they were there was so much like
shame for hippies and things like that
like doing things out of the norm
everyone's like wait you have to do the
same thing that i'm doing and if you're
not then something's wrong with you
so it's like you have roommates what's
wrong with you are you poor
it's like actually i am i just graduated
college i ho
what do you expect even if you go like
super minimalism is there something
uh that you like cannot live without
that is kind of like a
i would like to have access to a legit
bathroom
and a legit kitchen so like if i live
van life right it would be kind of nice
if even if i park it somewhere
i can walk in to like a like a
commissary or some kind of like group
thing and then you have access to this
to to being able to cook because i don't
like cooking and peeing and
showering in a confined space that's all
i see those extreme
luxury rvs yeah like the ones that they
open up on both sides and it's like two
floors where you can walk up the
bathroom gosh it's great
bigger than the size of this bathroom
yeah the kitchen's like huge where it
actually has a dining table there's a
type of rv's isaac wants to go rv trips
in
because like he's like we should go on
an rv trip i'm like okay like what's the
entry level rv and he's like he's like
watch
this youtube video he's like yeah we're
not affording that isaac those ones have
like
master bedrooms yeah yeah i mean he's a
man that has a taste
yes even when we pass through homes he
loves that
super super sleek contemporary modern
look
yeah like very clean lines and like the
homes and stuff
so i'm like i know what type of person
like what type of bachelor he's going to
be
he has taste he's he's an engineer
artistic boy like a like an architect
boy right yeah something like that like
very minimal
modern contemporary those square houses
that look like shapes and then there's
like one stone in the middle
yeah parasite oh that's a beautiful
house parasite home
those guys yeah
um when it comes down to that
life i think confined spaces
are okay if you are parked in nature
so like let's say your van is where you
sleep or whatever but then like
exceptionally the second you walk into
your living room you're not confined
like you have like everything gigantic
so that balance is okay
yeah but if you're parked in downtown
l.a it's just kind of sucks well cause
all right so like three things right one
is the the
the if you need to pee or whatever in
the middle of the night
um it's just that life you gotta just
kind of bend you just gotta live with it
right
another thing is like um noise so if
you're in the city
someone might bang on your door and [ __ ]
around with you
whatever your car might get towed
whatever those inconveniences i think
uh might [ __ ] it up a little bit
so but if you're in nature all the time
you don't hear
freeway noise you don't hear nothing so
i think that's cool
i know i've never lived in that
like in in quietness until now because
of the city that we live in it's like
super dead silent at night and it's just
so strange for me because my entire life
even that one year i spent in mexico
because my family's not from a ranch
they're from like the the city like the
main city
so i have never experienced what it's
like unless it's vacation time but like
just to live there i've never
experienced what it's like
like to just have zero sounds and then
only hearing nature like birds or
crickets yeah crickets or whatever it is
where i'm like this is
weird like it's really weird but it's
really nice it's a nice change
for me because it's just it's really
tranquil
and i'm able to like actually hear my
thoughts and i'm like whoa
it's so weird to not have the sirens of
like
police cars like every five minutes
that's what l.a is like
feel like if you actually do go and go
on kind of this pilgrimage for yourself
and like
get into this minimalistic place and
like leave the city and just go outdoors
and like stay really really chill and
stuff
are you also going to keep up with like
going ons
of society or news yeah i i mean it's
not come back and be like
what's been going on with this planet oh
kind of like jared leto
yeah he was good too weak so he didn't
even know kobe died
like nothing so yeah it was crazy where
was he at
he was in some like no like retreat type
of thing like silent retreat or
something dude imagine just coming back
like
that huge of a celebrity dies cold with
the world's lock down and you're like
that's exactly what happened to him yeah
that's crazy that's insane that is a
joke like there's just no way this is
real life
i still feel like i saw it all go down
and i'm like this is
imagine he's like going to some retreat
he's like just praying he's like
honestly
the world's so [ __ ] up right now we
need something terrible to bring us
together he comes back he's like
this is weird this is too full sorry i
asked for this i'm sorry he said bring
us together
you